[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT TAVIS: Welcome to Jumanji!
No, you're not
actually in Jumanji.
That was a joke.
OK, all right, don't
laugh at the same time.
It'll interrupt
with the recording.
Anyway, thank you for coming,
triple thanks, really.
Thanks for either getting
lunch quickly and rushing over,
or missing lunch potentially.
Thanks again for--
there's a keynote,
it seems, competing
with this, too.
So I appreciate you
guys coming here.
And then of course, you
guys get to hang out
in movie theater and super comfy
seats, super quiet environment.
So hopefully we can get
through slide six or seven
before anyone takes a nap.
There's no popcorn
today unfortunately.
And the slides are not in IMAX.
I tried, but not an option.
Anyway let's get
jumping right in.
So my name is Matt Tavis.
I'm a solutions architects.
And what that means is
I spend most of my time
working with
partners, customers,
internal product teams
trying to guide people
on how best to use the
Google Cloud Platform,
so what services to consume,
best architectural approaches.
I have an SA team
who focuses a lot
on building the solutions
you see on the GCP website.
So the Solutions section has
things that are downloadable.
That's what we do.
So we spend our time-- we try
and learn things from you.
And then we try and build
out templates and patterns
that make sense for
everyone to consume.
Later on, Sridhar will jump
up here, one of our partners
from Nutanix.
And he'll do a few
slides as well.
We'll do a quick
handoff later on.
But I'll let him
introduce himself then.
But without any further
ado, let's jump right in.
So I'd love to start by
talking about our perspective
on hybrid.
Hybrid's a pretty
heavily overloaded term
in the industry in general.
There's really no
single definition
that really captures it.
It's pretty broad.
When you look at
the dictionary, it's
really the two distinct things
that are blended together
in some odd way, that's hybrid.
So almost anything
could qualify as hybrid.
I'm going to talk about
how we feel about it.
And how we see Google
Platform contributing
to its further development.
But first, it's
important to realize
that hybrid is a reality.
I've ran into customers
in the industry--
I've been working in the cloud
for actually over 10 years,
so not always with Google,
with others as well.
And it is an industry
term that gets used a lot.
And often it's, well, hybrid
is not necessarily clean.
It's not necessarily pure.
But it's actually a reality that
most people are dealing with.
This survey you see
here, 87% of enterprises
are looking at a hybrid
strategy, have some form of it.
56% are already using
multiple types of deployments,
multiple clouds.
And only 40% are really
capturing cloud first
as a model.
And even the folks that
are doing cloud first often
have to go through
some transition.
Hybrid is a transitory
phase as well.
So you're going to probably run
into this unless you've never
built any software.
Who here has no software to run?
Excellent.
OK, good.
I mean, if you have
no software to run,
you probably have other
talks you want to go to.
This is about people
that have software.
They have to move it.
And how do you do
that in a way that's
efficient and makes sense?
So with that, hybrid is
persistent, and it's pragmatic.
One of the ways to
look at hybrid--
and I like to misuse terms.
So I like to tap in other
scientific disciplines
like thermodynamics.
And entropy is a
common term around how
things when left
alone, eventually
devolve into a more
chaotic state or maybe
a more natural chaos.
And hybrid really in many
ways is the expression
of that in the IT landscape.
As your platform evolves,
as you add new services,
new capabilities, as
you add extensions
to your architecture,
you oftentimes
end up in a blend
of technologies,
a blend of environments,
a blend of services.
And so this is something
that naturally occurs.
But that's not
necessarily bad news.
Hybrid, in fact, is actually
desired for many reasons.
So enterprises, in general,
often never single-source IT.
That's common knowledge.
Don't put all your
eggs in one basket.
So a hybrid strategy
is inherent if you're
going to use multiple clouds,
multiple environments.
The other thing is you
get some advantages
of extending your environment
with the best of breed.
So hybrid is an
opportunity to say, hey,
I've got the best pieces
from this platform.
And I want to blend
them with the best
pieces from that platform.
And that functionally
is a hybrid.
So there's some benefits
to that approach as well.
And then fundamentally
embracing hybrid,
which I think is what I'm
trying to encourage folks to do,
influences how you think
about IT and how you wield it.
So instead of thinking of every
transition or every migration
as a I'm going from A to
B, and B is my final state,
you recognize that hybrid will
continue to exist over time.
That means you adopt approaches
that are not about n plus 1,
but what's beyond that?
So if you're going from A
to B, what's C look like?
What are the tools
and techniques
I'm going to want to
use going forward even
beyond this current transition?
How do I think about
capturing and choosing
tools that are going
to benefit me over time
and not just for
this one period?
So thinking about that approach
differently changes perhaps
how you think about the
partners you select,
the tools you choose, and
the approaches you take.
So all in mass migrations,
people talk about them.
They're fantastic.
It's a great idea.
But even with that, over
time, the technology landscape
will change.
You will end up probably
in some form of hybrid
again later after
that mass migration.
So thinking about
how to tackle that
in a efficient long-term
way is definitely
beneficial to you
and your migrations.
So it comes in many forms.
As you can see here,
we have on the bottom--
well, let me see here, I've got
your left-- there's the bottom.
There you go.
We have an open-source-y,
cloudy type tools here,
and my data center or
more traditional bits,
some other cloud that's
not GCP, and, of course,
the Google Platform.
So a hybrid could be, I'm
blending two data centers
with disparate technologies.
Not as exciting for this talk,
but that's a form of hybrid.
Or I'm connecting my
traditional with a whole bunch
of cloud first or
cloud-native services.
Alternatively, I'm
using a common set
of tools, a common set
of open-source tools
across multiple environments.
Here you see Kubernetes
down below, GKE up above,
TensorFlow down below, Machine
Learning Engine up above.
So that's another blend
of hybrid technologies.
And of course, I would in my
definition of hybrid point
to multicloud as a
hybrid mental model
because you're actually
blending different approaches
and different
technologies across that.
So all of these really
are hybrid of a form.
And so there may be things
that you'll run into.
And they're all
valid and reasonable
depending on what
makes sense for you.
And then I'd like to
highlight that one.
And hybrid is, of
course, at every layer.
Thinking about hybrid, it's
not a particular architecture
inherently.
It generally is a
blend of things.
And so it actually fits.
And there's tools
that are needed
across the board at every layer.
Fundamental to the whole thing
is, obviously, networking.
There's no hybrid
architecture that I've ever
seen that doesn't
have a network in it.
So kind of makes sense.
So you have to have
a series of tools.
And you have to have a rich
platform and technology that
allows you to extend your
network as it stands today,
integrate other
services, and then build
a dynamic network
on the other end
to support your
hybrid migration.
So in GCP, we have a variety of
different tools from Dedicated
and Partner Interconnect for
bridging that gap as well
as, obviously VPNs,
and then things
like virtual private cloud, load
balancing, Cloud VPN as ways
to build out that
network on the cloud.
And that maps back to
your traditional routers
and switches that
you might own today.
At the next layer up,
you have infrastructure
as a service or tech capability.
So traditionally over here,
you've got your old VMs.
You've got your persistent
disk you might have.
This looks like a very
traditional, legacy,
virtualized infrastructure
in the enterprise,
and a series of tools like
the transfer appliance,
or even our new Velostrata
tools that actually allow
you to migrate VMs in minutes.
So that's how you get those
existing lift-and-shift models
to move those components over.
And on the GCP side, you've got
Compute Engine, Cloud Storage,
even Cloud Spanner to replace
maybe some traditional database
technologies.
Up top, the next layer of
hybrid is thinking about it
in the application approach.
So in the infrastructure
layer, you're
maybe blending some
different types
of services or components.
At the application
layer, you're saying,
look, I'm going to
pick a common tool
chain, a common set of
services, like Kubernetes,
across the board,
Istio across the board.
And I'm going to run that
in both environments.
So I can actually have a
single software development
stack everywhere.
And not everyone goes that
way from a hybrid perspective
because maybe they're
not in containers today.
But this is a fundamental model
that you see with our Cloud
Service Platform announcement.
We're espousing this idea of a
common tool chain everywhere.
But it does require
possibly some rewrite.
But that is
something to consider
is how do you get to that layer?
And that's a modernization
step generally
for existing applications.
And then fundamentally on top,
what I think a lot of folks
forget about in
the hybrid model,
is this idea of a common
set of services, API
management, visibility in terms
of monitoring across the board.
As you add the services
and capabilities
in multiple environments,
the management infrastructure
gets even more complicated,
so thinking about a way
to pick tools and technologies
that give you visibility
across the board,
like, for example,
Stackdriver which can work
across multiple clouds,
as well as even your
own platform or Apigee,
which can work across
multiple environments as well.
So those are
definitely key elements
to consider across the board.
Now our approach
to hybrid is what
I'd like to talk about next,
but after a drink of water.
I talked about the network.
The network is the foundation.
And without the
network, you don't
have a strong hybrid story.
And ideally, to make a lot
of these architectures work,
you have to have a rich,
global performant network.
And that's what Google's been
building for 18-plus years.
We have 17 regions,
125 points of presence.
We have over 100,000
feet of undersea cable
that we've invested in.
This is the largest private
network in the world.
And we continue
to build that up.
This is our continued
ongoing commitment.
This means that you
have access, when
you use GCP with your
hybrid environment,
to this entire network.
And as your data flows between
regions, between endpoints,
you have that
backbone that we've
built for our own platform.
And you can actually ride
on top of that world-class
infrastructure.
And we like to make it easy for
you to get involved in that.
So we obviously have
the Google network.
But we also build
multiple ways to get in.
There's premium versus standard,
different network approaches.
You can just do
VPN tunnels if you
want something quick and easy.
But we also have Dedicated
Interconnects or Partner
Interconnects where you can
drop in to a data center
that you're already in and
drop a simple 10-gig connection
across the data center to tap
right into the Google network.
So giving you that
flexibility is key.
And that is the foundation
of any hybrid solution,
that you have a strong,
scalable global network.
The other thing that's
important-- and this is more
of a positioning piece around
how we think about hybrid--
is that fundamentally, hybrid
if it's going to be effective,
it has to work in a lot
of different locations.
It has to come to you and
meet you where you're at.
So a principle
here-- and you saw
this in the Cloud
Services Platform--
is that we want to making it
better with open innovation.
So we're going to innovate with
the fastest that's out there.
We're going to build
the latest technologies.
We're going to give you the
latest tools on the cloud.
But we're also
contributing those back
into the open-source community.
So you can use the
latest TensorFlow APIs
and capabilities on a
machine learning engine
on Google Cloud, but also you
can use it in house as well.
So that's the fundamental
focus that we take
and why we think
hybrid with Google
makes so much sense
is because we're
going to give you a common
set of tools and technologies.
You don't have to
have developers
that understand the
Google service then
have to learn another service
for your in-house platform.
So you can actually
standardize across the board.
And this makes it portable.
It makes it extensible.
It makes it available everywhere
where you need to run.
And then, of course,
this innovation
that we continue
to contribute is
about not just delivering value
today, but also going forward.
So as we continue to
evolve Kubernetes,
we will do that in
GKE, but we'll also
do that in the Kubernetes
open-source project as well.
So you're getting those
innovations across the board.
These are some of the
key things in the last,
say, six plus months we've
done in the hybrid space.
I'm not going to
read all of them.
This is being recorded.
And I'm seeing
photos being snapped.
So that's awesome.
A lot of things we're doing
around the infrastructure layer
are this Transfer Appliance,
Velostrata, things like that.
Cloud Filestore just came out.
Partner Interconnect is
for tight integration
with your data center, they
give you a high throughput,
highly scalable
network, and then,
of course, five
plus or five regions
we've added onto the platform
in the last six or seven months.
On the application
layer, support
for things like Shared VPC, a
MemoryStore service for caching
in the platform,
Pub/Sub emulators
for various tools that
are common like Kafka,
private clusters to support
your architecture the way
it fits from an
application perspective.
And then in the
management space,
I think you saw a lot in
the Cloud Services Platform.
But even before that, we've
already been working strongly
on integrating Istio with
Apigee, having Apigee
expand to multiple regions.
We have a way to expose that
API layer over your applications
around the globe.
And then all the work in
IM in terms of conditions,
resource management
so you can not only
deploy your infrastructure
where you need it,
but also manage it in alignment
with your own security
practices and principles that
you have inside your enterprise
today.
And, of course, the
Cloud Services Platform,
which you've seen-- who's
seen that in the keynote?
All right, you're obviously all
asleep because I saw no hands.
Somebody saw it.
He's saw it.
That's two, four.
We're getting there, six.
So the idea here
is we want to take
what we've done in the
open-source projects like Istio
and Kubernetes, and we
want to make that available
where it's needed, which is
not only in the GCP platform,
but also in your
data center today.
And so, the Cloud Build
function, the Cloud Build
and serverless
capabilities for people
who are builders that want
an integrated workflow,
serverless as baked on
top of the GKE platform,
GKE On-Prem which gives you
the ability to run Kubernetes
both in the cloud and on-prem
in a consistent way, Stackdriver
and Istio integration,
so you actually
have the ability to see API
usage across your existing
infrastructure internally,
but also in the cloud.
And then fully managed Istio
is another key piece there.
And of course, this all
integrating with the Apigee API
management gives you a
single management plan
across multiple environments.
And so the way I look
at this is I actually
drew an architecture diagram.
Why not?
And so you see here,
there's a whole bunch
of approaches to the cloud.
And they're all represented now
as part of this Cloud Services
Platform architecture.
So here you've got
your Legacy/Cloud-Nope,
the things that never move.
They're very
exciting over there.
We'll leave them alone.
But they can actually
still connect to the cloud
with a Dedicated Interconnect
and then using the Apigee API
platform as a way to expose
legacy services with a web
service interface, a
very common approach
to help people expose
something that's maybe--
they want a way to
call into it, but they
don't want to have
to rewrite it,
so put an API layer
over the front.
And then staying on-prem in
the enterprise data center,
you can use GKE On-Prem
to modernize in place.
I want to improve
my application,
move to a modernized
architecture,
but I don't want to move
it out of the data center.
Maybe it's tightly
coupled to other services
in the architecture.
I can leave that there.
But I can add a managed Istio
mesh over the top of it.
So I can actually
control API access,
even though it's
in my data center.
And then, of course,
that same approach
can be applied to
my remote site.
So for example, I might
be a retail organization.
And I have hundreds of stores.
Well, guess what?
I got to still control
the services running
in the GK On-Prem
in those stores
as well just like I control the
services in my enterprise data
center.
So you have that
common model there.
And then here in
the Cloud Platform,
you might do
lift-and-shift where
you bring some things over with
Velostrata, but also the move
and improve, like I want to
move some features over and then
improve how they run
today, tying that
into the managed Istio.
And what you get with
this particular approach
from a hybrid
perspective is, one,
you get central
cluster management.
Now you can control
the Kubernetes that's
running across all
of your environments,
not just the one
that's in the cloud.
You have a centralized
way in which
you can view how those
clusters are performing,
what they're doing, and
upgrade them across the board.
You also have a Cloud Build
with a common tool chain.
So as I build containers,
as I build those artifacts,
and I want to deploy them,
I now have a common set
of services and APIs that
I can use across the board.
And I can deploy that to
any of those clusters.
And then the other
thing that's fundamental
to a true hybrid model is a
centralized API management,
this ability to capture who can
access what in my architecture.
So if you go down the
microservices model,
the ability to
say front end here
can call back end there, and
control throughput rates,
access to those various services
all through a centralized API
management [INAUDIBLE].
Now, that's obviously a
little forward thinking.
That was our announcement
this morning.
That's where I see hybrid
going to some degree.
And there's also a lot of
other tools in the space.
And we'll hear more about that.
But what we're seeing in
terms of real use cases today,
I thought I'd cover
that just so folks can
get excited about
what might apply
to their particular
business today.
So there's a few that
we see quite commonly.
One is this idea of invoking
legacy dependencies, moving
pieces of my architecture
into the cloud,
but calling back into
existing services
that I can't move today
or don't want to--
mainframes, large-scale
packaged applications
that have too many dependencies
to be picked up today,
things that maybe
run on infrastructure
that is not cloud ready.
But I want to still tap
into that from the cloud.
That's a pretty common front
end calling into a back end
model in hybrid.
Another is
cross-environment execution.
So I want all the
benefits of CI/CD.
And I want it fantastic
dev test process.
I want flexibility for
my development teams.
I want to move quickly.
But it turns out, I
still need to deploy
that code in my oil rig.
Well, that's going
to be a model.
You're not going to change your
oil rig necessarily tomorrow,
so, hey, the ability to use the
cloud as a cross-environment,
execution development
environment
is a common platform.
But deploying directly
from there to the edge
is common as well.
And then edge
computing in general,
I want to add a whole
bunch of sensors,
capabilities to my architecture.
I want to gather a
whole bunch of new data
that I've never
processed before.
I probably don't have the
processing power or the storage
that I need.
How can I use the cloud as a
way to extend my architecture
to capture all that information,
aggregate it, feed it back
into my existing
application, and then use
that as a blended hybrid model?
So some examples that, you
see that GCP front end.
I've got my back end
services, my existing stuff.
I then have all my
client traffic coming
through global load balancers.
I can hit whatever region
is closest to my customers.
I can capture all the front end
work that I need to do on that.
And then when I need to,
I can use an interconnect
back or a VPN back into
my existing architecture
and tap into other
systems like, say, ERP,
or back end inventory
management, things like that.
That's a pretty common
scenario we see quite a bit.
It might apply to what
you're doing today.
The other one we see,
as I mentioned, IoT.
Sure my devices are
going to continue
to reach back into my existing
on-prem infrastructure.
But then at the same time,
I can use Cloud Pub/Sub,
IoT Core, Dataflow.
And there's a whole array of
analytics and storage services
to capture, process, and then
aggregate that data so that I
can feed the results
back into my existing
architecture for maybe
output back to my devices.
So I have this ability
to take this maybe
smaller-scale footprint and then
add a whole bunch of managed
services and data processing
capability as a hybrid model
building, obviously, a hybrid
network interconnecting
between those two.
Some other examples
we're seeing is just
tapping into the
global network of GCP
as a way to get footprint
around the globe.
As you expand your
business, as you
expand to where your
customers are coming from,
you want this
availability everywhere.
You want to be able
to have the closest
location be tapped into.
So this global availability
of the 17 regions
is a huge benefit.
You can go from
tapping into one region
to get into that
network we saw earlier
to get around the globe.
Another is jurisdictional
or data sovereignty.
You might be tapping
into a new market.
And there might be rules about
where the data has to live,
has to be processed, and having
regions there available to you
right away, great example.
But you still want
visibility coming back
into your central
IT infrastructure,
so blending those data storage
and processing requirements
with tying it back into your
existing centralized approach
and architecture.
And then the last,
which is quite common,
is this idea of
extending an architecture
with cloud services.
I think IoT is one example.
I'll dive in another
one here, which is--
actually, let me
go back real fast.
Another one here, which is this
idea of, let's say I want to ML
or I want to add big
data, these things
are things I can tap
into my architecture.
And I don't have to rebuild it.
I just have to figure
out a way to pump
that data across and bring the
results back into my platform.
So in terms of
regional availability,
you can imagine
this kind of a model
where you have a
global load balancer,
you're exposing to
customers across the globe,
and then you're building
proxies in the regions, running
individual localized services
for various performance needs,
but then fundamentally
tapping that back
into an interconnect in terms
of feeding that data back
into your maybe centralized
or a lower-lessened footprint
enterprise platform.
The other one being the big
data example we talked about.
Yeah, I've got a
ton of applications
out over here that
don't fit on the screen.
I didn't think the screen
was going to be big enough.
So I was wrong about
that obviously.
So [INAUDIBLE] those
apps over here.
And then that data
is being pumped
through over a variety of
different capabilities,
whether it be a transfer
appliance, a transfer
service, or just a VPN
interconnect, whatever
makes sense into an event
stream, ETL streaming, staging
buckets, various streaming and
storage services that give you
your time series analysis, your
data warehouse on BigQuery.
And then you can build a
whole analytics and reporting
dashboard over top of that,
which can be exposed either
in the cloud.
Or you can even pump
some of that data
back for reporting on-prem.
So another common,
classic hybrid model we're
seeing in the market today.
So this is just a summary
slide that shows them again.
There you go.
But fundamentally,
we're obviously
doing a lot for the
Cloud Services Platform.
And we've been doing a
lot in terms of commitment
to open-source tools
and technologies.
But we also want the platform
to be open for our partners
as well.
Hybrid fundamentally
means a blending
of disparate technologies.
And we recognize
that many of you
are working with
existing partners today.
You have a wide array of
services or capabilities
that you're trying to bridge
into the Cloud platform.
And so we think that
it's as fundamental
that we actually make this
platform extensible and allow
others to participate as well
so your best choice tools
are available for you as well.
So whether it be multicloud
management capabilities--
that's why we expose
all of our APIs,
so you can actually tap into
that from a variety of tools
and management consoles.
Hybrid applications,
when you want
to run containers everywhere,
GKE allows you to do that.
You can run Kubernetes on-prem.
You can run it with
other hosting partners
as well, hybrid services
across the board in terms
of securing and monitoring
services across clouds,
and then hybrid infrastructure,
so that commitment to VMs
that can move around
V2V, V2C, that Cloud
Interconnect and data
migration are fundamentals.
And obviously, we
have a whole bunch
of partners in this space.
But what I'd love to do is turn
it over to one of our partners
right now to talk more about
his story and their solutions.
Sridhar Devarapalli
is a general manager
of cloud services in Nutanix.
Thanks, Sridhar.
SRIDHAR DEVARAPALLI:
Thanks, Matt.
Hey, folks.
My name's Sridhar Devarapalli.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, that's to you.
And my responsibility is to
drive forward our hybrid cloud
strategy at Nutanix.
And I'll talk about what that
means in the upcoming slides.
Matt's given you a
ton of information
on his perspective on hybrid and
the customer problems they see.
I would like to do the same
from the Nutanix standpoint.
Before I go any further, I'd
like to see a show of hands
as to how many of you have
actually heard of Nutanix?
Can I see?
OK, that's quite a few.
That's quite a few.
So let's start
there, just to recap
what Nutanix does as
a company and what's
our mission statement.
We deliver infrastructure,
data center infrastructure
for a customer's
on-premises environment.
And our mission is really to
bring cloud-like simplicity,
and agility, and cost economics
to on-premises data center
environment.
And we build a
turnkey infrastructure
stack that allows
customers to focus
on their applications instead
of low-level infrastructure
constructs.
We're about nine years old.
And we've got 10,000
customers so far.
And it's a fast-growing company.
So how do we
accomplish our mission?
What do we do to
realize our goals?
Well, to begin with,
we took a deep look
at data center technology
choices built and delivered
piecemeal to customers
and the operational silos
that they create.
Traditional
architecture is required
to plan and procure,
compute, storage, networking,
virtualization, all
of these independently
and manage the lifecycle
of each of these components
independently.
That results in long
lead times, dedicated
teams, specialized
skills, and, in general,
a pretty big operational hazard.
So what have we done?
We went ahead and
designed a new system
that coalesced all
those technologies
that you see on the left--
compute, storage, networking,
virtualization, management,
automation, orchestration--
and built an integrated, single,
turnkey appliance form factor.
And the result of that is
its unparalleled simplicity
as far as data center operations
are concerned and planning
is concerned.
And the value for customers
is evident from the rate
at which the company's
been growing with time.
Having said that, now what are
we doing with Google and GCP?
What's our joint vision?
I can get to that as--
yeah, there you go.
Our goal is to deliver a
seamless one-click hybrid cloud
experience and
platform for customers
to right-size their
applications and workloads
between private
and public clouds.
What exactly do we mean by that?
Essentially.
As you start from your
on-premises data center
environments, and you try
to figure out an access path
to the public cloud to realize
very specific hybrid use
cases-- and we'll talk more
about what those use cases
are--
we want to give you the
best seamless experience
possible without having to
go through the complexities
and transformations,
and redesigning,
and refactoring applications.
So that's the access path
that we've conceived.
And we'll talk more about
how exactly are we going
about realizing this vision.
There are a set of
capabilities that we're
offering to make
this hybrid journey
seamless for our customers.
And I'll break it down into
these three broad areas.
One is you've got to start
with transforming your own data
center because that's where
most of your applications
are running today.
And what have you done to
bring a degree of simplicity
and agility to that environment?
And that's where
Nutanix as a company
is bringing value
to our customers.
We're proven to provide
agility and simplicity
and transform your existing data
center to be more cloud-like.
That's been our
mission all along
and the success
path for us anyway.
Now, in addition to
transforming data centers,
we are also allowing
customers to transform
their applications,
redesigning them
to be more microservices-like
using technologies
like Kubernetes delivered
natively on-premises off
of our appliances.
Think of that as Google
services delivered natively out
of Nutanix platforms.
And our goal
eventually is that you
consume a combination of
Nutanix and Google services
irrespective of the location.
They could be
on-premises, off-premises.
But in the end, you can start
building your applications
in a way that you
progressively modernize them
without having to worry about
location and transformation.
Another key aspect, which is
related to what I just said,
is the ability to move
applications back and forth
between on-premises
and the cloud
without having to, again,
redesign or retransform them.
There's an offering that's new
that we call Xi Cloud Services.
And I'll talk more
about what that means.
Nutanix Stack for GCP,
Nutanix Xi for GCP integrated
with our on-premises offering
allow you to move workloads
back and forth as
your business requires
without having to
go through many
of the typical complexities
that one goes through
for cloud migration.
And related to
that is essentially
orchestration and automation of
placement of these workloads.
And I'll talk more about how
another product of Nutanix,
which is Calm, plays a big
part in solving that problem.
And finally, eventually
you want to get to a place
where you've refactored
the application
to optimally run in the cloud.
Therefore, you're
taking advantage
of all the native
cloud services and not
just doing the lift-and-shift
from on-premises to the cloud.
And we help you progressively
refactor those applications
through a series of
tightly integrated services
between Google and Nutanix.
So at the high level,
those are the capabilities
that we're designing together.
Now, what use cases do
they enable you to solve?
Again as I said,
any use case that
starts with your
on-premises environment that
needs to access the cloud
as a seamless extension
of your on-premises
environment would benefit
from these joint offerings.
The first and foremost,
disaster recovery and business
continuity.
This has been a problem
that's pretty hard
to address traditionally
because it's complex in nature.
And what we've done is we've
built a DR to the cloud
solution that's
tightly integrated
with our on-premises offering.
And with Google and
Nutanix together, you
can leverage the GCP
cloud as a DR target
in the case of a failure.
A related use case to
DR is lift-and-shift.
As we talk to many
customers, they're
looking to miniaturize
their data center footprint
and trying to figure out
a way to move workloads
into the cloud while retaining
some existing workloads
on-premises.
How do we make that
motion seamless
and allow you to
still have backward
connectivity and accessibility
to what's running on-prem
so that in the end you realize
that true hybrid situation
where your actual
workloads are spanning both
the public and private
cloud without you having
to go through, again,
a series of investments
and get us into migration
technologies and so forth?
And another use case
is cloud bursting.
And we'll talk about
a specific example
where there's a customer
who actually wanted
additional capacity in the cloud
based on fluctuating demand
from their users.
And how do we enable
that use case?
By allowing you to expand
into the cloud just as much
as your applications
need as though that's
a seamless extension of
your existing platforms.
So these are some
of the use cases.
And the broad theme is
that any use case that
is gravitated in your
on-premises environment
but needs either intermittent
or event-driven access
to public cloud services
will really benefit
from these joint offerings.
I got stuck a little bit here.
All right, sorry about that.
There was a little bit
of a technical glitch.
So, I spoke about
the why and the what.
Why are we embarking
on this partnership?
And what use cases
can be addressed?
Let's talk a little
bit about the how.
What product offering
specifically will
help us address the use cases
that I just spoke about?
And the centerpiece
of it all is actually
to enable a seamless
hybrid experience.
The first thing to
solve for is to keep
the same operational
paradigm, the same interfaces,
the same tooling,
the same workflows
to manage your applications
independent of location.
And there's a product
offering from Nutanix
called Calm, which stands for
Cloud Application Lifecycle
Management.
And it allows you to manage the
lifecycle of your applications
across multiple clouds.
And by lifecycle I mean
application deployment,
upgrades, expansion,
visibility, security.
All those elements
that you would
take care of as you design
and run your applications,
Calm gives you a
consistent interface
to perform all those operations
across different clouds.
And the way you
would do that is you
would create a Calm blueprint.
Think of that as a
set of instructions
that describes the constitution
of your application
and its infrastructure
requirements and dependencies.
And once you've designed
and built the blueprint,
you can repeatedly deploy
it across different clouds
while maintaining the same
operational consistency
in the way you manage
your applications.
The target cloud could be
a private cloud on Nutanix
or a public cloud like GCP.
And Calm allows
you to manage not
just the VM-based
applications, but also
containerized workloads as well.
Calm blueprints also
allow you to provision
and manage Kubernetes
through a control plane,
through a one-click experience.
Now, that's a little bit
about homogenizing consumption
and operational interfaces.
And that's what Calm
enables you to do.
But a true hybrid stack goes
beyond just consumption.
And where the need is to
ensure that all aspects
of your workload stay consistent
on both sides, including things
like performance, scale,
availability, security, data
protection, things
of that nature,
this calls for a different
level of building hybrid.
And by that I mean it's
the same platform that
needs to extend between
your on-premises environment
and the target public cloud.
And that's where our next
offering, which we call
Xi Cloud Services accomplishes.
That's exactly what it does.
Think of it as a native
extension of our enterprise
cloud platform into
the public cloud,
into various public
clouds, including GCP.
And it's our technology stack.
It's the same
software technology
stack that Nutanix has built
that we deliver on-premises now
is delivered as a service in
all in various public cloud,
including data centers
that we run and operate,
but also within the GCP regions.
With Xi, not only
do you maintain
operational
consistency as you're
expanding to public
cloud, but you
retain all the applications
SLAs and the security
model, and performance
characteristics,
and everything
else that you would
have carefully designed as you
built and run your application.
And you could do that only
because it's the same platform
on both sides.
And the first service that
we are offering with Xi
is disaster recovery
as a service.
And we plan to expand
the set of use cases
to encompass other
hybrid scenarios as well.
And specifically
with Google, we're
offering Xi services within
a GCP region colocated
with low latency access to
the rest of the GCP services.
So if you're a
customer who is looking
to transition to
the public cloud
for either your
existing workloads
or to build new
workloads, you can
leverage a combination
of Nutanix services
and GCP services through
this joint offering.
Now in addition to proximity,
there's a few more things
we're doing on the
interface consumption side
to make the whole
experience seamless
for our joint customers.
I'll talk through
some of those--
yeah, as I get the right slide.
A lot of this is the
platform integration
so to enable and ensure
a seamless experience.
So firstly, it's going to
be an integrated portal.
There's a common portal
from which customers
can consume a combination
of Nutanix services
and a select set of GCP services
that we will make accessible
through this portal.
And those select
set would be the set
of services that
would make sense
to consume from within Xi,
things like BigData, BigQuery,
that can actually act
on your data that's
residing within the Xi
Cloud Services anyway.
Another common problem
that customers experience
is management of credentials.
And through a single
sign-on experience,
we allow you to maintain
a common identity
to access a combination of,
again, Xi and Nutanix services
so that you don't
really have to manage
a different set of credentials
for each of your employees
or operators who are
managing and administering
these resources.
We consolidate bills.
And you get a single
bill from Nutanix
that captures both
charges related to GCP
and charges related to
the Nutanix Xi services.
So you're not dealing
with two payment systems,
and two ways of
tracking your bills,
and things of that nature.
And finally, this is important,
and Matt touched upon this
before also, which is
network connectivity.
And establishing
network connectivity
is really usually very
cumbersome and painful.
We unified that in
the sense that you
could use a single
network connection
to access a combination of both
Xi services and GCP services.
And that connection
could be a VPN connection
over the internet, or it could
be a GCP interconnect as a way
to reach a combination of
GCP services and Xi services.
And if you see all of these
capabilities together,
the goal is to enable a more
seamless, simplified experience
to access what we call a
set of hybrid services.
So I spoke a lot
about essentially
various capabilities,
and mission statements,
and use cases, and so forth.
Let's bring all of it together
using an actual customer
example.
Here's a real
scenario where there's
an existing joint customer
of Nutanix and GCP.
And they were interested
in essentially procuring
excess compute capacity
on the fly, on demand,
as and when their
application needs it.
So during peak seasons,
it's an application
that serves both internal
and external users
for that organization.
And during peak
season, they need
capacity for that application
to expand on demand.
It's a pretty standard
web application
that consists of
Apache web servers,
and Oracle databases, and
JBOSS application servers.
And primarily they wanted
the web server capacity
to expand on demand
without human intervention,
and without any lead times, and
without overprocuring capacity.
Now, it's a pretty standard
cloud bursting use case.
And I'm sure many of you've
heard of this case before.
But it's pretty
hard to accomplish
without the right
degree of automation
and without having to
retransform or change
the nature in which
your application is run,
especially if you're
looking to access
the public cloud
as a way to procure
that additional capacity.
So we've implemented
or are in the process
of implementing a solution
for this customer that
includes a lot of the
components that we spoke about.
The Calm acts as the
overarching orchestration layer.
And it's constantly monitoring
performance and utilization
of the application.
And it's built to orchestrate
new web VMs in GCP.
This is actually
within Xi in GCP.
And therefore, if you need
more capacity on the web
without any kind of operator
intervention, the system
itself detects that,
OK, it's reached
a threshold, at
which point it needs
to spin up these instances.
And it launches them,
adapts them to the web farm.
It does other forms
of automation,
things like assigning
IP addresses,
building connectivity back to
the on-premises environment
where the actual database
runs, and modifying DNS records
and things of that nature,
all the automation tasks
that you would
otherwise manually do.
And we leverage,
as I was saying,
that common network connectivity
between GCP resources
and Xi resources as a way
to establish connectivity
between on-premises and
the cloud environment.
And there you have it.
Essentially, this is how we've
solved this customer's use
case.
And if you see, it's
because of the fact
that Xi is running inside GCP
that this automation has become
amendable in the sense that the
customer's workloads need not
have been transformed
in any way.
There has been no redesign
of their applications.
The way they've constructed
their virtual machines
and the way they've
designed and characterized
performance for
their applications
on their on-premises platform,
all of those characteristics
are retained as these instances
burst into the public cloud.
It's a pretty simple
example, but it illustrates
essentially the power
of the joint solution
because it addresses
things like automation
and seamless expansion without
the need for refactoring
your applications.
And the benefits to customers
is really the simplicity
that it brings to the table
and the economic advantage
of adding capacity
only when you need it,
guaranteed availability.
This is a pretty business
critical application.
And therefore, guaranteeing
availability and performance
SLAs for this
application while you're
taking advantage of the
economic elasticity is critical.
And it also illustrates
the way in which
workloads can be moved.
I showed you a cloud
bursting use case.
You can clearly see how
this can be extended over
to a mobility use case
where instead of bursting
into the cloud,
you could actually
move that entire application
over into the cloud using
exactly the same constructs
and the same tools
that we built to
address this use case.
Anyway, so hopefully
that gives you
a sense for the why,
and the what, and the
how, along with the
actual real example
that illustrates what
we're bringing together
between Nutanix and Google.
So I will be around
in the Nutanix
booth in the conference.
So if you have any
additional questions,
myself and my colleagues
would be happy to answer them.
Thank you for your time.
And have a great afternoon.
MATT TAVIS: Thanks, Sridhar.
[APPLAUSE]
Appreciate it.
I don't think we
have any more slides.
But I think the point that
we were trying to make here--
if I can wrap it up--
is really our goal
at Google is really
to provide you a hybrid solution
that meets you where you're at.
Depending on what you
need for today's approach,
it fits your business
needs, as you've seen,
it can move existing
applications.
You can modernize and improve.
You can abridge networks.
You can provide all the
tools and capabilities
to meet you where you're at and
to help you meet your business
goals in what is the
most efficient fashion
for your business going forward
as you go into your cloud
transition.
With that, we
actually have a twist
ending to this movie,
which is that we actually
have a time for questions.
I didn't think we were
going to have that.
But it turns out either I talk
too fast or I missed a slide.
So there are microphones
on that side and this side.
Or if you want to
scream it at me
because you're in the
middle, and I can repeat it,
that's an option too.
But we have a little
over five minutes.
If you have no questions and
want to run away, I get it.
Thank you very
much for your time.
And we look forward to
seeing you at the conference.
Oh, and don't forget, if you
are running away, tomorrow--
and the only reason
I'm plugging this is
because I'm proctoring--
Cloud Hero is an
interactive DevOps game
if you want to literally
build an app real time
for a challenge to see who
gets the highest score.
There are prizes.
And there are capes
actually, oddly enough.
You should look for us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]